welcome to data of is deaf talk I'm your
host - Kazi our today's guest is even
starry even is one of the winners of the
visualize 2030 contest he is a cover
student attending McMaster University in
Ontario Canada what yourself what are
you busy with these days yes so right
now I'm currently attending McMaster
University
but right now I'm on internship and at
this internship I'm using data studio
and using visualizations to present data
to our clients in a meaningful way how
did you become interested in
deregulation in the first place what got
you into it yeah so I think it all
started even before my internship where
on reddit I would always follow the
subreddit called data is beautiful where
people post these visualizations and to
the community for them to showcase
showcase so I think that's really where
it all began in my interest came from so
you are interested in data visualization
even before like you started building
busy but as you started building your
own realizations how do you get used to
data studio what has been your
experience with this tool yeah so that's
the first question I think at my current
internship use data studio to present
data to our clients and provide insights
using this visualization software and I
think stepping into the software that my
experience has been great overall and
its ease of use really stepped up to me
it's just so easy to use and when I
first started on my internship I had no
experience with it but yet I could still
build these dashboards for our clientele
that just shows how easy it really is to
use you use these for you and you build
a base for WH 2030 contest and that was
actually one of the winning entries
there so congrats on that thank you
maybe you can take the audience through
the biz and tell them the story you are
trying to tell throughout the interview
realization for sure yeah if you want to
take a look here yes so from I visualize
20 30 project I wanted to focus in on
two of the scg's of know poverty and
climate action so that's what I really
focused on with my interactive is so as
you scroll down I kind of show
statistics on what's happening in the
world today and
bring awareness in general to what's
happening and one of the key findings I
found out that 71% of the total
worldwide emissions come from these
high-income countries and we're actually
not noticing an increase with the
middle-income countries as you can see
here as they move from low income to
middle income classification we're
noticing a huge co2 emission increases
per capita for these nations so as you
can see I continue to add interactive
visits to my data studio project as I
really wanted to give the audience a way
to interact with it and find their own
conclusions to the problems and here
people are able to select an individual
country and really dive deeper into say
a country of interest or if they want to
see just particularly what's happening
in a certain region of the world they're
able to see specifically what's
happening with the poverty improvement
GDP growth and climate action in these
nations so I also included what must be
done and what can we do to make the
problem better and I think the key
takeaway for me was that we're going to
need to find a way for these low-income
countries to develop sustainably whether
that's to high-income country aid or
worldwide international funding we're
going to need to find a way for these
low income countries to develop
sustainably so we don't decrease poverty
but also increase climate action at the
same time what do you think about data
studio as a tool for anyone that's
trying to do data storage going and
cranking social change yeah so I think
really we all know that words only go so
far and I think providing insights to
graphs or visuals sometimes provides a
better context on these social change
issues so I think the industry really
provides an easy and accessible way for
people to use another platform to reach
out and try to provide change to these
problems we face in the world today so
for someone who's just getting started
with the tool who's someone that doesn't
have any experience in building their
own data visualizations or doesn't have
that much experience in their
storytelling how can they get started
what tips would you give them
you know have a really compelling story
right so I think that's something
actually that my co-workers always talk
about a lot and I think the very first
thing is just start simple whether it's
you know one graph or one bar chart or
one visualization for that matter it
really doesn't matter where you start
and I think building off that one
visualization is important and don't try
to do too much at once and really just
start simple and start with just
anything really even thanks again for
being on the show you can learn more
about the visualize to 8:30 contest and
look at the winning visualizations from
the links in the description for more
details to your content be sure to
subscribe to the GCB Channel and you can
always visit our site at
developers.google.com slash data studio
until next time keep building morbus
[Applause]